well for two consecutive days china has
violated taiwan's airspace by flying
military jets around the self-governing
island unannounced taiwan's premier soo
jin chang has slammed the flight saying
they jeopardize regional peace the
flyovers are seen as a show of force
during the week-long commemoration of
chinese national day two separate
sorties flew into taiwan's airspace on
friday on saturday another two waves of
fighter jets were flown in the defence
ministry in taipei says a total of 77
military planes entered taiwan's defense
zone
now from taipei i'm joined by dw
correspondent joyce lee joyce beijing
often launches these kinds of missions
to show its displeasure about comments
made by taiwan what's prompted these
particular incidents
so this largest incursion came on the
national day in china and now beijing
fails to unify the island one day by
force if necessary so it's a pressure
tactic used by the chinese authorities
on taiwan and some experts
think that it's also
china is trying to
put pressure on the international world
not to support taiwan especially
after taiwan
applied to join the cptpp
has there been any official explanation
from the chinese authorities
no they haven't made any public comments
yet but uh previously beijing uh said
that such flights were to protect its
sovereignty and
aimed at
collusion between taiwan and the united
states the latest incursion also came
shortly after beijing denounced taiwan's
foreign minister joseph wu as a
shrilling fly
for his efforts
to promote taiwan internationally
now taiwan's premier has condemned these
flyovers but how are people on the
street there in taiwan reacting to this
show of force from china
um in the latest uh incursion
there were several uh h-6 bombers which
are capable of
carrying nuclear weapons so this is
obviously something serious but to
ordinary people in taiwan life goes on
because um beijing's harassment has
become a new normal here
for the past two years
chinese military jets fly over to
taiwan's defense zone on a weekly or
even daily basis so
people here are
quite annoyed with it but they're also
used to such threats
all right dw's joyce lee reporting from
taipei thanks very much
you